since the construction of the
international space station started to
wrap up
in the late 2000s nasa has had the idea
to construct an iss
for the moon over the years nasa has
received support from multiple
presidents for the lunar gateway
and they have sunk billions into the
project but just last year
nasa announced the lunar gateway was no
longer a critical path
to the moon so why is the lunar gateway
feeling
to take shape well
taking a look at the origins of the
lunar gateway will find ourselves in
april of 2010
at the time president obama called for
nasa to complete a crude mission to a
nearby asteroid
nasa would quickly determine that such a
mission would be infeasible
astronauts would have to spend months in
the spacecraft and the technology simply
wasn't ready yet
so nasa would reject this planet but
ironically
they would propose an alternate plan
that was arguably even crazier
this alternate plan was the asteroid
redirect mission
the idea was that a spacecraft could go
and grab a small near-earth asteroid
and take into orbit around the moon this
way
astronauts could go and live in the
spacecraft attached to the asteroid
and explore the asteroid over a long
period of time congress
wasn't a big fan of the idea though they
didn't believe that the mission was
either practical
or useful this rejection would lead us
into 2017
where nasa revealed their vision for the
modern lunar gateway
nasa proposed a two-phase plan with the
first phase calling for an assembly of a
collection of space modules
in a distant orbit around the moon
called the deep space gateway
they originally planned for this phase
to be completed by the late 2020s
at which point they could move on to
phase 2 which was a deep space transport
the deep space transport was simply a
large spacecraft that could shuttle
astronauts from the moon
to mars nasa hoped that assembling the
spacecraft at the deep space gateway
would reduce the difficulty of launching
such a large spacecraft directly from
earth
this plan wouldn't quite pan out either
but it would take on a new form
you see president trump would call on
nasa to not only send astronauts to the
moon
but also build a new permanent presence
in space the guidelines for nasa weren't
too strict
so nasa would build upon their past
learning spaces and ideas and propose
the most ambitious version
of the gateway this version involved
help from many of the space leaders
around the world
including russia japan europe and canada
the gateway was proposed to have nine
different modules including a habitation
module
a robotic arm a docking component and a
plethora of science modules
at this point nasa was basically just
pitching the idea of building iss
for the moon though extremely ambitious
nasa was able to garner support from
several space leaders
so it seemed like the lunar gateway
would actually take shape but this
is when vice president pence would
completely redirect the focus of nasa
in march of 2019 pence wouldn't cancel
the lunar gateway
but he would put out a goal that would
require basically all of nasa's focus
pence wanted nasa to return astronauts
to the moon in 2024
given this new goal nasa would be forced
to completely change around their
priorities
and timelines they would cancel or
postpone everything that wasn't required
to return humans
to the moon and unfortunately the
majority of the lunar gateway was not
required to return people
to the moon but this brings up the
question
if the lunar gateway is not required to
return people to the moon
why was nasa spending so much money and
effort on the project
in the first place given that we haven't
been able to return humans to the moon
in nearly 50 years
you would think that getting to the moon
would be a top priority and that all
distractions would already be cut out
well the answer to this question is
extremely complicated
as there are several experts on both
sides of the argument
some think that the lunar gateway is a
no-brainer for long-term human space
flight
while others suggested the lunar gateway
is an utter waste of time
money and effort so let's begin by
taking a look at the proponents of the
lunar gateway
starting with nasa themselves nasa
claims that there are three primary
reasons to support the development of
the gateway
with the first being the power and
propulsion element the lunar gateway is
expected to support a 60 kilowatt solar
electric propulsion system
top of the line communication systems
attitude control and orbital transfer
capabilities
nasa argues that positioning all of this
tech near the astronauts visiting the
moon
will significantly improve the
likelihood of a successful mission
for instance even if the astronauts were
not able to communicate with mission
control
on earth they may be able to contact the
lunar gateway
similarly if something goes wrong with
their rocket they may be able to stay on
the self-sustaining lunar gateway
basically astronauts traveling to the
moon will have more options available
if a major error occurs with the mission
nasa's second argument
in favor of the lunar gateway is the
gateway's ability to act as a habitation
and logistics output till now we have
only completed a couple of manned
missions to the moon
and all of them were rather short apollo
11 for instance
only included 21 hours and 36 minutes on
the lunar surface
their short mission durations can be
explained by the fact that there was no
long-term living facility located right
next to the moon
astronauts in the apollo missions had a
limited amount of food and resources
so they couldn't just spend six months
at the moon the lunar gateway however
would make this possible
astronauts could live inside the lunar
gateway for several months at a time
and complete dozens of trips to the moon
along with this
we have nasa's third reason for
supporting the lunar gateway which is
its logistical capabilities
the gateway would be much larger than
nearly all modern rockets
so nasa can use the gateway for storage
and transportation purposes
before each lunar mission nasa can send
a wide variety of different experiments
and testing equipment to the lunar
gateway and during the mission
the astronauts would be able to bring
back lunar samples and conduct various
tests on them
at the gateway itself the ability to
conduct tests near the moon would allow
nasa to conduct many more tests
and be much more flexible after all to
get more lunar samples
you don't have to launch another rocket
to the moon you just have to descend to
the lunar surface
and collect some more samples that's the
main three reasons that nasa offers
on their official page about the lunar
gateway but there is one more advantage
that proponents of the gateway
often point to which is a transition
point for a martian mission
getting to mars takes about six months
with today's technology
so a large spacecraft with a nice
sleeping bathroom
and exercising facilities would be
optimal launching such a spacecraft
directly from earth is extremely
difficult
due to the large size of the spacecraft
but what if we launched components of a
large spacecraft into space
piece by piece and assembled it in space
like the deep space transport plan
suggested
the hardest part of launching a large
spacecraft is getting it
into space once the spacecraft is in
space
it's much easier to move it around due
to a lack of gravity air resistance
and drag by following this plan
astronauts could simply fly in a regular
cramped rocket to the lunar gateway
and at the lunar gateway they could
transition into the large spacecraft to
complete their journey
to mars this would heavily reduce the
pressure of trying to build a massive
rocket that can fly directly from earth
to mars not to mention this would give
the astronauts a much more comfortable
way to travel
so that's the points that proponents of
the gateway bring up
now let's take a look at the other side
some notable critics include former nasa
administrator michael griffin
and the founder of the mars society
robert zubrin these critics argue that
the lunar gateway is not only a money
pit
but completely pointless like most space
projects the lunar gateway is expected
to cost a lot of money coming in
at 40 billion dollars and let's not
forget that space projects tend to often
overrun their budgets by
quite a bit so it would not be
surprising to see the gateway end up
costing 60
or even 70 billion dollars something
else to consider
is that going to the gateway to get to
the moon add 17 to the fuel cost of
getting to the moon
aside from costing a massive amount of
money building the gateway would likely
take several years
it took 10 years to build the iss itself
and that's only in low earth orbit
imagine how long it could take to build
a space station in lunar orbit
the worst part though is that all that
money and effort
doesn't even give us any new
capabilities sure having a lunar gateway
would be convenient for conducting
experiments with lunar samples
but it's not like those same experiments
can't just be completed on earth or
at the iss what about astronaut safety
though
building a lunar gateway can
significantly improve the safety of
astronauts visiting the moon
well the primary argument against this
point is that we can just build a lunar
base
instead why spend all that money and
effort on building a lunar iss
when you can just spend all that money
and effort on building a lunar base
a lunar base would accomplish all of the
functions of a lunar gateway
better if you're going to argue that the
gateway is convenient
well the base is even more convenient
you can live
and conduct experiments right on the
moon if you're going to argue that the
gateway provides greater safety
while the base provides even more safety
with the base
you don't even have to send to the
gateway to return to safety or
contact mission control most importantly
though building a lunar base would be a
major step forward
in terms of space exploration we've
already built a massive space station
so building one for the moon would be
more of a sideways step building a lunar
base though would give us valuable
experience
that could help us eventually build a
base and city on mars
basically people who are against a
gateway argue that i learned base and
the gateway offer very similar pros
and cons so why not just go ahead and
take a bigger leap forward
and build a base instead of jacking
around with another space station
as for what nasa plans to do though the
gateway has been postponed
they haven't completely ditched it quite
yet but given the strong opposition from
credible experts
it's very possible that the iss for the
moon will never end up happening
that's not necessarily a bad thing
though it just means we have more money
and resources to build a lunar base
instead do you guys support the lunar
gateway
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited to finally see
humans return to the moon
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one